hallo mein name ist aber okay ich dachte
wohl zweimal sagen
jetzt präsentierte eingeblendet meine
lieben fall etwa voreinander
die sind bereits im titel eingeblendet
heute machen wir eine wer würde er
challenge ich gegen meine schwester und
meine mutter stellte fragen hinter der
kamera
ich glaube das ist mir ehrlich gesagt er
würde sich eher mit einem eher oder auf
die schnauze
das war eine blöde situation mehr wollte
sie von euch bei einer er sich auf einer
party betrinken und hier eher nach oben
gemacht
das habe ich das letzte mal durch
angerufen wenn wir sprachen lernen da
etwas war was meinst du gestern ja der
biegsame operiert werden musste november
ihre zweite kamera das ist also ich
werde ab und zu mal ein bisschen auf die
zweite kamera switchen
[Applaus]
aber wer ist als erstes ausgeben würde
definitiv sarah
den er mit duschen fertig sein und
monroe schwierig immer wenn wir hier zu
hause sind jetzt gerade auch über die
weihnachtstage die ganze zeit warte ich
immer richtig lange darauf dass ich
überhaupt ins bad kommen war sarah zählt
glaube ich duschen beim die prozesse
nicht nur das duschen dazu sondern auch
das ganze drumherum
dafür würde er das zimmer aufräumen
also das dann brauchen wir gar nicht
reden müssten bitte an
ich meine ja auch schwimmen im zimmer
unterm bett und sophie dahl damit dort
war das spricht ja für dich chaos es ist
in der kritik beziehungsweise kreatives
chaos
hallo wer würde als erster von euch vom
zerspringen denke hier unnötig da hoch
zu gehen und dann runter zu springen so
dann ist er wieder da unten und nass und
es tut weh wer würde er begrüßen film
angst bekommen
so darf ich glaube wir da tun wir uns
nicht viel wir würden auch niemals einen
film gucken hat er sich den sinn hatte
auch nicht bezahlt geld dafür dass du
angst hast ein bisschen unnütz nur wer
würde er pünktlich zu einem wichtigen
spiel gesagt
200 zu einem wichtigen termin in
wichtigen die mediale kraft unpünktlich
sein aber ich bin eigentlich immer
unpünktlich das müssen wir jetzt an der
nächsten arbeitgeber dann schickt
menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich abstoßen
wer würde er um gut zu werden lügen ohne
rot zu sarah war also entschuldigung
aber man merkt man das direkt eine
schöne sagen als kind okay aber das
waren kleine notlügen aber an sich ich
bin noch auf einem für euch wer würde er
ein frosch tun zu mund beatmung wieder
zum leben zu erwecken
ich denke davon fünf aus punkt alter
[Musik]
wir haben amazon dann wieder okay wer
würde er in tanz sowie unser thema
tanzen was mich gar nicht als kamera
will weiß ich nicht du keine ahnung hast
du das wird auch nicht in mannheim auf
dächern in altenheime antanzen senioren
obendrauf oder bestimmt als hinter den
tanz von jerusalem können wer ist von
euch er von null auf hundert wenn er
sich ungerecht behandelt fühlt oder sich
angegriffen für beide beide also ich
glaube wir sind relativ von der zeit her
gleich schnell
und da wäre ich noch kritisiert noch ein
bisschen videos gerade in whatsapp beim
schreiben und was gefällt mir selber
fast jeder zweiter werden würde er das
ergebnis von 7 x 8 56
ich bin ich halt macht macht er heißt
der flächenberechnung kreisky meierkord
werde er von seinen gut spenden
also muss ich sagen weil ich muss mich
auch immer hinlegen wenn blut bei mir
abgenommen wird weil ich sonst war ich
so groß bin und so breit weil ich sonst
zusammenklappen
also halt wirklich noch so angst vor
nadeln und spritzen so nähe das null
also angst davor habe ich nicht aber ich
merke dass mein kreislauf direkt ab sagt
klinikum körpersprache sein wie ich auch
sagen auf jeden fall wenn ich mich an
activity naja activity und auch wegen
youtube und so alleine hätte ich jetzt
sagt wenn du sprichst dann hast du viel
so meinst du dass ich dachte sind zum
pantomime spieler alle gegenüber so dass
wir dann nicht
ich bin sehr overdick was du was
manchmal an mit auch mit gestik all ihr
geld da bist du eigentlich das wäre dann
in dem fall aber wer ist besser
beherrscht würde ich sagen gebraucht
werden dürfen euch er einen knopf exakt
angeben können an der hin- oder annehmen
also noch wer würde dann reicht er auf
den mond fliegen wollen wir wollen ja
ganz ehrlich mich reizt das halt 0,0
mich gehabt selbst wenn zehn euro kosten
würde würde ich sagen ich mache es nicht
ja ich glaub mir zu langweilig als wenn
müssten wir das so komplett mit 1
freunden machen dann wäre es wieder fest
mit 30 leuten der würde er
seine ehrliche meinung sagen habt also
auch in peinlichen situationen oder ohne
jemanden daran zu haben den man zu
versetzen
[Musik]
ich lebe ich jetzt sehr weit aus dem
fenster ich würde auch sagen ich bin
viel zu betrunken um behauptet er würde
er einen film schauen zum beispiel
scheint die soko laden verträglich denn
löwen oder spotify laut und lästig und
doch fährt als erster auf eine einsame
insel überlegen
ich bin so aufgeschmissen ohne komfort
wenn er was sagt man wenn man sich für
eine schlägerei auf dem parkplatz eines
automobilherstellers treffen will
komforth anderer stelle durch das
heutige video das das ganze auch rein
geschrieben haben falls auch geil wieder
das video dann begonnen hast mit da
sehen wir wieder wenn also jeden tag
auch im youtube-video vergehen würde ja
mama könnte so ein blog auch haben
interieur-design 10 wege wie man mit
stress umgehen kann dass du nicht kann
man mal kurz wenn euch das video
gefeiert das kann einen daumen hoch und
ein video hier da was sollen die leute
noch machen richtig muss doch nicht sein
jeden tag zu viel
[Musik]